all right Patrick is with us in Memphis
Tennessee
hi Patrick how are you as you always say
I'm most certainly better than I deserve
very cool how can I help
well followed you for quite a while and
as you always say I'm at the point where
I'm sick and tired not being sick and
tired
right tired of making that a portion of
our budget good so as we're going
through our debt snowball which we are
in occurrence that snowball one of our
biggest is our vehicle we currently the
current payoff I just looked this
morning is 30 mm oh yeah $32,000 the
worth of the vehicle according to na da
is only 22 and so it's our only vehicle
and so I'm trying to figure out and
we're a family for I'm trying to figure
out what the smartest decision for our
family is what's your household income I
work two jobs one's a salary at 50 and
the second is a part-time and I've
probably brought in 20 this year yeah as
a flasher you own way too much car yeah
and so you know I don't think you're nad
a number is accurate I would go to Kelly
Blue Book and look at private sale
kbb.com and private sale be a lot closer
because I think you've gotten a trade in
number on this unless you rolled some
negative equity from the previous deal
into this deal you shouldn't have a ten
thousand dollar spread on a $30,000 car
well we were also we were sort of stupid
when we bought the vehicle it's got the
extended warranty you can cancel that
you can yeah okay so we've got that on
that and we also it was an emotional
purchase and so we walked in knowing
that's what we want and we walked out
getting it not paying attention to you
think you might have overpaid yes okay
but they wouldn't have charged you more
than sticker so I I mean let's say you
cancel the warranty and that's three
grand and let's say twenty two is twenty
five well that starts to change the
whole picture then and the 32 becomes 29
you know the value is actually 25 and
the
after the cancellation the extended
warranty now we only got a four or five
thousand dollar spread you borrow the
difference
who's got the loan on this mess Toyota
yeah they're not gonna help you okay the
the car company finances finance
companies are no help at all on this so
you got to go to your local credit union
or your small local regional bank where
you can go in sit down talk to them in
person and you're gonna get a loan for
the difference if you don't have the
cash saved to cover the difference in
order to get you this to where you can
sell it and and then you need to go and
get you the cheapest possible car that
you can get with cash and get you know
and then start saving to buy a better
car with cash and move up and move up in
car move up in car then you get rid of
car payment you're going of your life
back this thing owns you guys it's it
owns you in a bunch of ways number one
you are well aware that the purchase
process you used for it was completely
impulsive immature ridiculous and you're
shamed by that every time you look at
the stupid car and so that's it's gonna
set you free to get thing out the
driveway in that regard I've done a lot
of stupid stuff I don't like down the
stuff around me to remind me I'm stupid
I try to get rid of that stuff that's
what this thing is doing it yells at you
you're stupid every time you walk out of
the front yard I want to get rid of it
for that reason alone but on top of that
it's way too much car and then this time
we're going to start being wise with all
of our purchases including vehicle
purchases this is the Dave Ramsey show